season three of the masked singer is
just days away and no one knew truly no
one is more excited in these two kids
right here that's all I need to say
that's right we catch the sound board
it's a sound board and we are ready to
use it at any moment guys we are back
for season three we're excited but we're
even more excited because we can't
believe our bosses agreed to let us do
this after-show again please hold
exactly we have had our detective hat on
for weeks looking at costume reveals and
we are stoked to break it all down for
you today that is correct we're here to
tell you everything you need to know
about the masked singer season three
here's your who what when where and why
who well we've got all the same players
as last season that is correct host Nick
Cannon is back and of course our
favorite judge panel is still there
Jenny McCarthy Ken Nicole and Robin I
[Music]
have a feeling we'll be hearing plenty
of that again this season
what is new you guys is the costumes
this season we're going all out we've
get this 18 contestants which is more
than applause for the Fox with a
community we have 18 contestants now
correct that is more than season one
which only had 12 contestants and season
2 which had 16 and of course we've been
keeping tabs on the massacre Instagram
page and all the different articles
where they've been publishing and
announcing these and we are gonna run
through everything we've got for you so
far let's do it first up we have the
llama this is just cute it's it's
adorable that's four legs I big like
fully went for llama here this is like
one of those Halloween costumes that
I've never pulled the trigger on but
fully maybe intend on doing this year
the inflatable ones that would have the
leg yeah correct
so I can't imagine how much fun the
llama is gonna have trotting around
product promises also I love the like
tourist look he's going for here with
the camera the like the floral looking a
shirt up and next after the llama we
have one of my favorites the banana he
is very appealing guys I judge
every time Charlie has a stupid pun
we're gonna play that sound effect
listen Nick Cannon has the bad puns I
have to one-up those and give you even
worse well you did a good job thank you
thank you I love this very like I don't
know it looks like something a little
nas ex would wear with like that oh that
would the jumpsuit look I think he's a
little busy kind of coming up his Grammy
high but he would be good honest I do
love the banana next up after the banana
we have miss monster who is a relative
of season one's monster our winner
t-pain yes and may I take this time to
please note on our upgraded beautiful
new set we actually have a picture of
t-pain back there they're taking his mr.
monster costume on yeah which is awesome
I'm wondering though is Miss monster or
someone connected to t-pain a lot of
people think it could be his wife I
think possibly someone who he's worked
with or maybe produced in the past this
next costume here we have the Frog
wearing a dapper looking suit might I
add mm-hmm total Jim Carrey mask vibes
yes not someone who I think would do the
math singer I don't want to jump to
conclusions that was a good one I'll
give her the airhorn that was a good one
guys thank you so much but adorable
these are all just getting cuter and our
detailed and like this is almost like
fashion forward completely completely I
love it and following the Frog we have
the robot here very industrial correct
doesn't look comfortable to dancing
we'll definitely see that no it's you
know it reminds me of the Jetsons
Charlie's probably too young to even
know what the Jetsons are really okay
well maybe this is someone who loved
that show okay
following the robot we have one of your
favorites the kangaroo
I just love anything with nods to
Australia okay I love koalas I love
kangaroos it's interesting that this is
a boxer mm-hmm and Oscar De La Hoya fun
fact he used to sing so I think this
could possibly if it is a man I don't
know it could be him manifesting it
already
I love the whole look the boxing gloves
it's all like bedazzled yeah that's a
good one and swaggy look at those that
bling-bling right I know and following
him we have this one the white tiger so
I was thinking about this one I off the
bat my first gut instinct tells me Odell
Beckham jr. why is that okay first of
all no one is swaggy er then
Dell Beckham jr. and look how iced out
this white tiger is also he went to LSU
home of the Tigers Wow too obvious too
obvious I'm gonna cricket myself stay
tuned though she could be right
following be white tiger we have the
pretty slick-looking
turtle this turtle gives me Charles Aoki
vibes anybody else Wow
the spiked I didn't have that haircut I
had this bike tarawa not sure if you
have a leather jacket like that I like
the color green I'm not the turtle but
I'd wear this it's like a biker turtle
kind of a biker turtle and I think it's
interesting because we can't tell if
this is a guy or girl right well they're
doing that more this seat on purpose
where you're really kind of left in the
dark and it could go either way one that
really leaves us in the dark is this
next one this is the astronaut I mean we
can tell nothing like yeah there's not
even eyeballs on that one no I don't
know how they're seeing and all gold
everything is a win in my book okay I'll
take it following that one we have the
Katie listen this is what I would pay
this is yours if you guys ever want me
to be on the masked singer I would like
to wear something like this the Katie's
giving me like very burlesque vibes Oh
les kitty to her role in burlesque I
will fall on have a conniption fit and
melt could also be shared let's just
dream big give it a moment Rima big
that's right I'm following the kitty we
have the Swan this is interesting
Natalie Portman is that you Black Swan
but make it a musical but make it white
oh this is I know I said I like the
banana clearly I have a thing for the
food costumes yeah me too Atok Oh guys
we have a singing and dancing taco with
a cherry tomato yes and they drop this
on Tuesday which I think was intentional
Taco Tuesday like they know what they're
doing over there and up next is one that
we actually saw in the teaser coming out
of the finale from season two but we
haven't officially seen this costume
debut on the massive Instagram it is the
mouse this is again very fashion-forward
I feel like this could be a Gucci fall
2020 look it could be a Rodarte fall
2020 look and I for many reasons think
that this is Paris Hilton but I'm gonna
get into that later in the episode
listen it's definitely giving me some
cheesy vibes
move along
our back was actually just announced
this is the Rhino
I love the rhinos look very
fashion-forward again that jacket is
something I would probably purchase
1,000% that's like a shearling suede
boss look look at that beautiful scarf
with some fringe yeah I mean everybody
is really bringing their a-game it's
season three no time to play guys no
time to play and the mass singer is
definitely going on a safari journey
this year as we saw through a few and
we're here for that wild ride the
contestant stats are equally as
impressive as the costumes so you guys
let's run down what everybody has
achieved it's a lot
we've got 69 Grammy nominations 88 Gold
Records 11 Super Bowl appearances three
stars on the Hollywood Walk of Fame a
hundred and sixty tattoos and one title
in the Guinness Book of World Records I
will know exactly who it is after I sit
at my desk the Guinness Book of World
Records and go through every single page
I you know I hate that they told 160
tattoos that could be one person guy it
truly could only one that could be
someone like Travis Barker the guy
doesn't have any that's not correct and
it's really hard cuz these people are in
costumes
yeah it's not like oh I can identify
like something that they've achieved
that's like a physical clue somewhere in
normal annoyed there aren't a few other
good ones in there though I'm excited to
see how they play off I mean three stars
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame those are
some legends for sure yeah yeah you're
not getting one of those without like a
serious career we are exactly and what's
new this season and the biggest change
that is coming
are the eliminations the competition
will now be tournament style we have 18
masks contestants all of them will be
divided into three groups a B and C we
have three groups of six each group will
then compete against each other until
there are three contestants left in each
group those three groups of three will
come together and be our final nine
competing for the golden mask I'm really
all about this I am too I think it's
gonna make it a lot easier to keep up
with 100% I mean you guys know we know
last season we got so invested in every
one of these contestants
and then it sometimes felt like weeks
went by where we hadn't seen them
perform it was like you performed at the
beginning of the month and then it went
through a whole nother month and we
never even saw you now we're gonna
really get a chance to be super invested
in these costumes and these talents and
I feel like we'll do a better job of
analyzing if we see everything back to
back exactly and we know exactly what's
coming each week we have group a B and C
we'll see them in the same order and
that's something that's exciting me a
lot totally what we're fun job well done
producer props to the master for that
you're for now we appreciate that but
work on trimming that next week but
staying the same one celebrity will be
eliminated every episode however there
is another change again this is more of
a bonus for us than a change we already
have the clue packages we see every week
before they sing and we also have the
physical clues that come out after
performances but now we are getting
celebrity relation clues so we are gonna
seek from contestants friends and family
members in masks with disguised voices
this is a genius move absolutely genius
I said at the at the top of the show I
do think Paris Hilton is doing it this
season imagine seeing her sister Nicci
her dad her mom her BFF Nicole Richie
imagine them putting on a mask talking
with a disguised voice and giving us
intel that only they would know well
also we won't even see done so we're
gonna have to know we'll have to guess
I'll guess who the family members of the
masked singer is there's a lot of
mystery here happening but I think
they'll be giving us little nods that
could lead to a lot more research for
sure and as far as the guest judges go
Jamie Foxx we mentioned I don't know so
many times last season Fox managed pun
intended
Fox managed to wrangle him and he's
gonna be on the panel on premiere night
we also know that Jason Biggs and Leah
Remini so funny we'll also pop up at
some point during the season as guests I
think they're both great guest judges
who will add something and definitely
some comedy to them yeah the the
comedians do the best job Joel McHale
was my favorite hands down guest judge
last season he had me peeing in my pants
the when and where well view masked
singer season three debuts immediately
following the Super Bowl on Sunday
February second you know it's that like
small football game it's kind of a
warm-up for the massing I really IT up
our favorite show the show will continue
airing weekly on Wednesdays at 8 p.m. on
Fox and of course here's a nice
shameless plug you can watch us every
Wednesday night two on ET online.com ET
live and 80's youtube channel all the
platforms guys alright the why is
frankly very simple it's because we are
obsessed with this absurd amazing
incredible gem of a show why do you why
do you it's a lot of lose that's how we
feel about the show
yeah let's whoop it up for the masked
singer why do you why do you love
watching this show it's insane I mean it
gives us something we have so much fun
in the office it's not just us involved
with the son of your mower all of our
co-workers want to guess who these
people are they want to get involved the
group chat is lit it's truly like eyes
um I think it's just absurd it's fun and
we see a lot of celebrities we haven't
necessarily seen sing or perform or even
in the spotlight recently for sure and
not only do we get that entertainment
factor on the show I mentioned this many
times last season I am such a sucker for
a redemption moment and so many of the
stars that go on this show unfortunately
are going through maybe a tough time in
their life or maybe a professional slump
and it's so nice that this show kind of
breathes new life into them and allows
them to kind of be behind a mask just
show their talent have fun dance really
dance like no one's watching because
you're behind what we're watching but
like the inhibitions go away when the
mask is up you don't have to worry about
the the pretense or the height you just
go out there and do your thing and like
Michelle Williams and and what she did
last season I like I cried yeah there's
a bad singer here and over Michelle
Willy and I'm not apologizing for it
well we are obviously thinking of who we
want to be on this season we're and we
can expect a very big unmasking ET
actually spoke with Robin Thicke and
Jenny McCarthy earlier this month at Fox
tcas and they said it's bananas
literally take a look we have already
shot the season three premiere and the
the unveiling on this one is the biggest
shock yet I'm still in therapy for it
none of us guessed it Jamie Foxx is our
first guest panel judges and all of us
got it so wrong that when you watch at
home you guys are gonna be like
screaming at the TV Robin Thicke is in
therapy as a result of the shocking
result of the premiere night we can't go
in therapy because we have an episode
that following Wednesday correct
throughout this whole season we're
expecting something big obviously yeah
and they know that the stakes are super
super high I have to believe these
producers and these judges are committed
and they're gonna give us the season of
their lives and speaking of which I want
to know who is on your dream guest list
that you would like to see perform a
mission I know during the finale of
season two I threw a lot of Disney names
out there grew up with the Disney
Channel I got Raven Symone out there
yeah I got Adrienne I got my Cheetah
Girls reunion mini reunion there are
obviously a lot more I would like to see
one of them being Lisa Vanderpump
interesting Real Housewives Real
Housewives we saw in that teaser I know
you're thinking more Paris Hilton yes we
definitely saw a few big Hollywood
figures we saw the Beverly Hills sign
I'm thinking maybe Lisa and her small
dog are ready to compete on the
massacres look she did Dancing with the
Stars that way so the woman likes to
perform I am gonna plead though my case
for Paris Hilton so first of all simple
life like just give me a thumbs up if
you love the simple life as much as I
did growing up Paris is obviously a
performer she's put out music before it
would be a natural fit in that capacity
but if we want to talk about that cool
package that you're referring to
we saw the Chihuahua no I know lisa has
a lot of dogs but so does Paris Paris
has a chihuahua of her own Tinkerbell or
sweet angel little Tinkerbell and the
other big clue was the numbers that we
saw on the gate those are actually the
numbers of where Paris lives so if you
do a little google search you'll see
that the other big reason why I think
it's Paris is because of this I did a
little investigative research on her
Instagram now the masked singer season 3
has been filming throughout December and
January he's still filming right now to
correct Paris is known she loves
Aspen she loves the holidays in Aspen
interesting person take a trip to Aspen
this year in fact no hashtag no Aspen I
think it's so interesting that her
Instagram is basically just stock photos
of herself she's been going to LA event
she went to like the Golden Globes
after-party she's been to a few
premieres we have not seen her in New
York we have not seen her in Switzerland
you know she's always DJing all around
the world I think Paris is filming the
masked singer the other big piece of
evidence is that she has something to
promote she noticed earlier this year
she's gonna be doing a YouTube
documentary so this is a perfect vehicle
to help her promote
if you haven't heard slipping is her new
term I think her doing the masked singer
would be living living love it we're
here for it we love it there are a few
other names I would like to see I talked
about how much I love the food costumes
obviously someone who is very known in
the food world and the mean world is Guy
Fieri no he'd be killer killer I would
love to see Guy Fieri in a taco costume
I mean even the spiky hair kinda reminds
me of the turtle costume dude a pork
sandwich a brisket BBQ no syngress could
you imagine
he's got so much personality that guy
truly though it could be anyone under
those masks and the one thing we do know
according to production creative Tiana
and Gandil men there is someone
unbelievably tall on their season take a
look we are pulling all the stops
one in particular includes a very tall
tall tall singer and I can't wait to see
how it all comes together because we've
never seen anything like this before
first off I know what you're thinking I
am tall it's not me how tall are you
six foot four okay so you would
definitely qualify we qualify for one of
those tall costumes but they weren't out
you haven't known I haven't been asked
that Lee guys I brought him out she's
been it works good um so when when we
saw this I immediately start thinking
she said Paul singer now obviously she
is a producer she's got to protect
herself it could be an athlete or
someone else
in the public eye but she said singer so
I started googling tall singers the
first person that came up and this would
make so much sense Montell Jordan the
singer of the iconic 90s Bob this is how
we do it I would love to see him have
like a second wind on this show and and
we know he can sing I mean oh he's a
performer he's I believe six foot five
also rapper 2 Chainz she's about six
foot five and if we want to talk about
the ladies
Jane Lynch and Macy Gray are both about
six feet tall which is tall I'm sure I
think it's like throw us for a loop and
I don't know if we'd recognize their
voices necessarily I mean we heard Jane
on Glee but I don't know if I'd be able
to pick her out with the disguise
talking voice well we're experts we sit
we sit until we find enough stuff on the
Internet to prove our research program
exactly why they are horn Dedra that's a
perfect introduction it's because you
know we have so much fun Charley and me
sitting here on the show every week kind
of picking apart the clues but we wanted
to give a little more structure and some
fun posess for season three so we're
gonna be introducing some new segments
that you can expect from us hopefully
every week um the first of which is
gonna be called the masked singer ringer
the puns don't stop they don't stop take
the word ringer quite literally we're
gonna be phoning friends and taking
names so for example if you think it's
Lisa Vanderpump yeah we could possibly
call Bryce sander who is a host and
producer here at et online he's our
housewives and all things Bravo experts
so we'll get his expert take on it but
also we're gonna call celebrities guys I
went to college with Vanderpump rules
star Stassi Schroeder
I'm gonna call Stassi and be like yo
where's Lisa Lisa Vanderpump in a tell
me give me the scoop I love that we also
have another big one it is called screw
that's exactly screw the clue we are
going to be calling out and setting the
record straight on a lot of those those
clues that are trying to throw us for a
loop we saw a lot include packages last
season I'm trying to trick us I think it
was Jessica Simpson we saw some clues in
there when it was really Kelly Osbourne
yeah we know we're watching they're
trying to steer us in the wrong
direction but we are calling it out
[Music]
trying to make just think it was Jamie
Foxx last season now that we know it was
Wayne Brady the third and final one is
gonna be called reality check now look
Charlie and I we love the judges but
let's be real like us they sometimes
miss the mark yes so in a very very
loving way we're gonna be giving them a
little dose of reality and setting them
straight and we also want to let you
guys know that in the spirit of the
Super Bowl that small small sporting
event happening this Sunday at export
sports we are going to be doing a little
bit of our own this season let us know
what you think we should wager on the
line and we'll announce the terms of the
bet during the Super Bowl post oh I
truly think there are a few things we
won't do no the bar is very low and let
us know what you think alright guys well
that does it for us at least for now yes
we will be back and live on Sunday after
the masked singer airs following Super
Bowl 54 so please make sure you join us
and per usual we'll be diving deep into
clue packages analyzing performances and
doing all the detective work with our
magnifying glasses yes we will we want
to know who do you think is on the show
this season which costumes are you most
excited about
tell us using the hashtag a team a
singer let the masked malarkey begin
that's the best I guess love and I love
Little John bye guys
[Applause]
[Music]